У Верховній Раді знову неспокійно.
Там вирішують долю підконтрольних сепаратистам
територій Донбасу.
Для врегулювання ситуації на сході України
Петро Порошенко вніс до парламенту
два законопроекти. Про реінтеграцію Донбасу та
про подовження дії закону про самоврядування.
Перший проект спрямований на забезпечення
державного суверенітету України
над підконтрольними проросійським сепаратистам
територіями.
Другий продовжує на рік дію закону
про особливий статус місцевого самоврядування
на Донбасі, ухвалений ще в жовтні 2014 року.
На думку експертів, це своєрідне страхування
на випадок, якщо не вдасться прологосувати
перший документ, який експерти називають
основним законопроектом.
Так, згідно з текстом законопроекту,
непідконтрольні Києву території
Донецької та Луганської областей,
зокрема сухопутні території,
внутрішні та морські води,
а також повітряний простір,
визнаються тимчасово окупованими,
а Росія - країною-агресором.
Згідно із законопроектом, тимчасова окупація -
нелегітимна та не надає Росії
жодних територіальних прав.
Не мають ваги й документи,
видані так званими "ЛНР" і "ДНР".
А Україна не несе відповідальності
за протиправні дії країни-агресора,
її збройних сил, інших військових формувань
та окупаційної адміністрації - кінець цитати.
У Києві кажуть, що визнання Росії агресором
дає можливість посилити
дипломатичну позицію України щодо того,
що в майбутньому росіяни не зможуть
входити до складу миротворчих місії на Донбасі.
Ще один важливий пункт - це відмова
від режиму АТО, який діє з 2014 року.
А функція військової та політико-економічної влади
покладається на Оперативний штаб.
Спільно з СБУ він контролюватиме і переміщення
осіб і товарів на тимчасово окуповані території
на спеціальних контрольних пунктах.
У документі йдеться і про права громадян,
які з початком воєнних дій змушені були
полишити свої будинки й переїхати.
Так, за фізичними та юридичними
тимчасово переміщеними особами
зберігається право власності та інші права
на майно, зокрема, на нерухоме,
зокрема і земельні ділянки.
А з урахуванням визнання Росії агресором
у людей з'явиться можливість домогтися репарацій.
Законопроект показує бажання держави
повернути під контроль окуповану частину Донбасу,
однак підтверджує при цьому відданість
Мінським домовленостям.
Особливий статус окупованих територій
стане реальністю тільки після виведення
з території України незаконних збройних формувань
і їхньої військової техніки, а також
після проведення там виборів
відповідно до українського законодавства.